[Music]
hello my name is bradley and trust me
google
facebook and instagram already know this
and today
i'm going to be telling you everything
they know about me and also how they use
this information to get me to buy things
like
cheese and gym memberships
[Music]
but first of all let's tap into the
origins of targeted advertising
now the picture you see on screen is the
1908
ford model t this was a car that put
millions upon millions of americans
behind the wheel for the first time
now by 1927 ford's factories had
produced over 15 million
model t's now that's 30 times more than
tesla produced
last year needless to say the model t
was a genuine revolution
not just for the automotive industry but
for advertising as well
henry ford actually once said if you've
got a really good thing
it will advertise itself so that's why
up until 1923
ford hadn't invested a single dime in
advertising the model t
yet still ford did supply its dealers
with all sorts of informational
materials and brochures
now indeed it was the dealers who did
all of the pr work
for instance the dealers would actually
work with local newspapers
and magazines to tailor advertisements
to the needs of their local clients
who they knew much better than the ford
company in fact
dealers would spend up to three million
dollars a year on this sort of
advertising and bear in mind this is the
1920s so this was an absolutely
ludicrous budget for the time
nonetheless this approach proved
successful and by 1918
every second car in the country was a
ford model t
have you seen this banner before it's
horrible isn't it
but the funny thing is this is the first
and probably the most effective banner
in the history of the internet
on october 27th 1994 thousands of people
visiting the site hotwired.com
saw that banner and 44 of them
actually clicked on it landing them on
the at t
website you will and the company that'll
bring it to you
at t by comparison today a banner is
considered successful if it's clicked on
by
five users out of a thousand now in
marketing this ratio is actually called
the ctr
which effectively refers to the number
of clicks on your link
compared to the number of impressions it
makes
but why have banner ads suddenly gone
away i mean you didn't really see them
anymore
well simple there were just too many of
them
you see that fateful atmc banner
triggered an epidemic
and within a few years banners appeared
on the vast majority of websites
in fact there were so many banners that
we could no longer distinguish between
them
now renowned usability expert jacob
nielsen
called this the nascar effect there's a
good reason why
take a look at this there are so many
different sponsors on the race cars that
they all merge into a single
indistinguishable mess of logos and
symbols
now we can easily distinguish between
the cars but we can't actually discern
the individual brands themselves
now the thing is because advertising
these races is so expensive
sponsors are willing to be present even
if it means they cover just a tiny
silver patch
on the race car itself with banner ads
the opposite actually occurred
at first banners were placed manually on
the websites but then soon enough
so-called banner networks came along and
they served as intermediaries
now these are effectively ad exchange
systems in other words if you showed
someone else's banner on your site you
then had the opportunity to show
your banner on their site and moreover
you could configure things like the
location and
the themes of the sites where your
banner was actually shown now in a way
it's quite similar to how ford
dealerships used
local newspapers for advertising they
couldn't tell exactly who would be
seeing the ads
but they could assume the interests and
the needs
of the readership anyhow the banner
craze led to networks and site owners
trying to show as many of them as
possible
and in turn well we internet users
adapted
slowly but surely banner ads became
something that we would instinctively
ignore
[Music]
[Music]
obviously it didn't take long for ad
agencies to see the huge potential in
online promotion now just five years
after the first banner ads appeared
a man named bill gross patented a
revolutionary technology
now his idea was to show ads that relate
to the web page on which they're shown
soon enough this technology was actually
purchased by the then
leading search engine yahoo
bill gross's invention led to the
emergence of an even more tailored type
of advertisement
one that's based on your search engine
queries on the one hand this can be seen
as a good thing right
i mean it will be easier for you to find
the information that you need for
example if you're a texan
looking for a place to fix your car
you're not going to be bombarded with
ads showing repair shops in alaska now
at the same time your web browsing
history
is being saved which means that the
search engine delivers advertisements
based on your previous search history
so once again we're faced with this
choice between comfort
on the one hand and privacy on the other
if you want to retain your privacy while
searching the web i actually recommend
using a search engine that doesn't save
your search history
duckduckgo is actually an option here
you might have heard of this one now the
engine is based on the idea that the
user needs to be given access to as much
information as possible therefore the
user can decide for themselves
based on non-targeted relatively
objective search results what they want
to buy
and as such the search engine does not
store web browsing history cookies or
any other tracking data
so i'd like to conduct a little bit of
an experiment now
we're going to enter something into
google and then we'll enter the same
thing into duckduckgo
and compare the results so let's enter
something simple like
car repair this goes with our earlier
example
you can see that it automatically knows
i'm in london
i'm getting recommendations very
specific to the place that i am
okay so you can see i've got some
recommendations here
so it's clear that google already knows
where i am
not just the fact that i'm in london but
also the fact that we're in central
london
let's enter the same thing into
duckduckgo let's go for car
repair now you can see you actually have
the choice
so you can choose where you want to
search in the united kingdom
or is it all regions right or is it
argentina or belgium or brazil
something like that and you can actually
go and you can get very general
objective search results so it's not
storing any data about me
which is brilliant for privacy 4.5
billion people
already use the internet and the total
traffic has exceeded
40 zettabytes in other words that is a
ton of data
too much data for my comprehending right
now for example if i wanted to search
the word
banner on google right it's clear that i
get over 2 billion results
now this is why search engines use
something called a filter bubble
mechanism
now this means that the search engine
displays the results it thinks is
suitable for me
and this is informed by the data that
it's constantly collecting now this
includes my search history my website
visits
videos that i viewed on youtube and so
on do you want to have a look at what
google thinks about you
well it's really easy click the link in
the description and you'll see yourself
through the eyes of the search engine
itself major search engines can still
collect information about your interests
even if you don't click on the search
results directly and instead you might
opt to enter the urls into the search
bar
so how does this happen well it's pretty
simple
for instance google offers a convenient
tool for websites called google
analytics
now this effectively offers easy-to-use
reports about visitors popular and
unpopular pages and
ultimately how users are navigating the
site in general
while the site owner can't track the
individual visitors
google can in fact google can track
what you do and it can also store the
relevant data in your personal profile
so the more time you spend on websites
that use google analytics
the more accurate your digital profile
will be
and this means that google can point
more and more targeted ads towards you
[Music]
online stores spend a lot of time and
money to get you to click on their ads
obviously
but according to statistics most people
who click on their link
will actually leave after just visiting
one page
this could be because of a lot of
reasons i mean maybe they haven't yet
decided to make a purchase or maybe they
don't have enough time to place an order
or even enough money in their account in
any case
they're still known as hot customers
because they've already shown their
interest in the product
now if this is you advertisers are going
to be targeting you again
and again in attempt to make you
complete that purchase which you didn't
do prior
so if you've ever clicked on an ad and
then found yourself being bombarded by
similar ads or the same ad
over and over again you're effectively
being retargeted by these advertisers
they've captured your interest and now
they're pushing you to buy now it's not
only search engines that are collecting
your personal data
social networks messengers and mobile
apps collect information on your
location
activities and even the contacts of your
acquaintances
now oftentimes it doesn't even occur to
us that we're being
spied on now what do likes tell us
i'm talking about the sort of likes when
you go on instagram and you like a post
or on facebook right
now even a few likes can reveal your
gender and age
for example this little research project
let's have a look you can tick
the six photos that you like more than
the others
and believe it or not a neural network
will actually determine your age
and your gender based on your selections
how mad is that
so if just six likes makes this possible
can you even imagine what facebook and
instagram already know about you
much too much too much too much too much
recently
signal messenger launched an ad campaign
in which they use narrowly targeted ads
based on
job details geolocation relationship
status and personal interests
now these ads reveal to users just how
much
is known about them to advertisers and
the result is
kind of creepy
[Music]
you probably remember one of my recent
videos where i explained how you can
delete your social media profiles
if you didn't get a chance to don't
worry go over a look after this video
it's really great but
i would like to now expand on a few of
those points that i made well what i'm
talking about is that facebook knows
much more about you than what it reveals
what i'm talking about specifically the
creation of a shadow profile
now in other words this is a vast amount
of personal information that's
indirectly collected from you by
facebook
now what's quite scary is that you don't
actually need to have facebook to
have a shadow profile created for you
all it takes is for your friends to
share your contact
with facebook now remember facebook
asked you to access
your contacts so it can find friends
quickly well
if you answered yes to that question
then your address book
content was made available to the
network including phone numbers
email addresses and all the information
connected to people on your phone book
who have never actually
directly shared this information with
facebook at all so here's my advice
never share your contacts with facebook
even if you've got nothing tied
because your friends might
we had a good discussion yesterday
now the good news is that it's actually
quite easy to restrict applications on
your phone by managing permissions in
the settings
it gets a bit more complicated with
websites however because on websites
these settings are often hidden in the
depths of the interface that's why i
recommend using aggregators
like simple opt out these can disable
personal data collection
as you surf the web
so let's wrap it up hopefully i've
illustrated how
invasive the advanced targeted
advertising technologies have become
so maybe this will give you something to
think about next time you make that
unexpected online purchase guys look the
key to keeping your personal information
personal
is meeting people in real life go to the
bar have a drink with your mates don't
talk to them on facebook or
share their contacts with facebook it's
just an invasion of privacy
anyway my name's bradley and this is
some sub
we'll see in the next video
you